ah
ça aussi c'est une constatation qui est
un peu pessimiste mais qui pourrait
s'inscrire en faux contre le fait que
les français sont racistes
alors des exemples de racisme s'il vous
plaît
ne gonfle pas paulette me confl pas
déjà que j'ai passé toute la journée au
boulot et puis je vais dire j'arrive à
l'accident de panique marseille ben non
j'ai rien si c'est pas fait tu sais pas
qu'est-ce qui manque de denrées non un
noir
et tu sais la petite rue en bas la scène
mondiale feront d'un congrès y toujours
web à lui j'ai arrêté profond
j'arrivais derrière et pouget rentrer
dans le chou mais il est en centaure
mois moi j'espère bien qu'il est dans
son coeur et je vais dire tu sais pas la
meilleure il traite de racine moi
raciste
non mais franchement raciste tout ça
parce que je dis ban en bambou lattes
avec un grief
pas fait rire bon chemin ils ont bien dû
nuancer mais flo
tu disais ça pour rire marcel bien sûr
mais tu sais bien je suis pas raciste
avec les [ __ ] mois
mortman au plus je suis pas raciste en
lançant quand même chacun sa place en n3
ce qu'il faut pas mélanger les chiffons
avec les
bennes ou à marcel avec les mouchoirs je
crois
non gamin quand il rentrera de l'école
bastien beaucoup de l'école l'a vu ses
notes en français aux petits
qu'aux d'assurer nord-ouest 5 t'as vu le
nom du pro au body donc au bon d'accord
les chinois parlent tous français tu as
vu ce
building paumé mais qu'est ce qu'ils
vont food est d'aider des professeurs de
lettres et jaune là pour apprendre à
jacter correctement petits français et
franchement non mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ce truc que tu fasses quelque chose
on peut je vais pas laisser passer ça
non non je veux dire bon je vais y aller
1 3 1 se brider là je vais lui dire ses
ces mecs là c'est tous des champion de
karaté champion de karaté de moi je veux
envoyer dans ses rizières
bouge pas
bon d'accord c'est pas du jeu voir c'est
le directeur de l'école parce que le
gamin il peut avoir un prêt des
percussions surtout qu'avec ces mecs là
faut se méfier les saucissons des
relations mais c'est toujours la
banlieue c'est sournois sénégal sans
être ainsi ça va bien sur que non c'est
pas du racisme dans cette semaine alors
[ __ ] qui fondent dans le chouf phase
qui se met à nous parler français à la
maison et puis alors attend ce soir moi
je rentre le voisin du dessus la pucelle
antillaise à l'afrique voilà alors on se
retrouve ensemble dans l'ascenseur le
maire confirme la forte ni menti me
regardent comme ça une fête c'est ce qui
me fait non quelque chose à l'équipe le
chalaux
non je me suis que j'ai vu dans ses yeux
là il me poignarder nous violer tu me
retrouve en petits morceaux dans la
décharge du coin
heureusement pour les habite au deuxième
étage tu vois c'est ce qui m'a sauvé
leur sert non les camemberts
j'en avais acheté 3 parce qu'ils étaient
ensemble à dos et mbia là
bas ça durera buts et tu vois ça en
fait tu peux leur dire merci au
camembert
bon c'est pas le tout que ça fait un
bond fespa diori en mer est trop cuit
non on va boire mon bain tu fais du ori
bah quoi tu roules tu fais le travail
des étrangers en france du
réveil s'est emporté de taïwan puis
c'est bien moi je m'étais dit ça va nous
changer des nouilles a fait la peau du
cou ce compte pendant pire voilà
écoutent ils vont pas s'infiltrer chez
nous jusqu'à dans la bouffe alors je
viens quoi on doit jeter un oeil aux
chiens à jaffe cure des patates batak
allumé la télé font consommer français
lundi gouvernement royal et voyez à la
télévision
c'est un petit feu
devient
wars et le théâtre y pense
mais ils sont partout regarde ça c'est
encore un pascal légitimus
rapport en bronze et je vais dire
chez
stone
& chandon et mais parce qu'ils
disaient
il ya tant de petits jeunes la conduite
allant qui donne un vrai qu'à travailler
et étrangers comme ça qu'ils viennent
jusque chez nous et pourquoi je me
demande bien pourquoi tu sais pourquoi
mais non mais il est rangé 20 et pouvoir
il est pas moins c'est sûr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]